the day this airs February 1937 Sue's
[ __ ] possible the trajectory of my
personal brand careers changed forever
well how much how much time how much
time do I have perfect and how many
people will be in attendance you think
roughly fantastic
Drock you want to get the most awkwardly
placed bathroom
against me here hey Rayna hold up oh wow
good good are you
man I'm deaf Fantasia so I'm let's
finish up in Andy huh hey how are you we
started kind of a business and then we
went like let's go broader like let's
take let's take your sort of point of
view the motivation the time to love the
whole sort of like the broader sort of
value and apply it to ya business but
also like other things that people are
trying to weaken most with time it's
like MTV made right getting a 16 year
old to get the prom date that he wants
frankly those are higher concept there's
a lot more production there's a lot more
moving pieces you got to cast the right
people you got to go on location it
takes a bunch of fun and I have a fun
belief that a lot of people you're
talking to talent wise we're gonna need
that to carry the day dad I don't
totally very so so like just give me
some snapcash let my team look through
10,000 kids pitching ten-second ideas
and then I'll watch a hundred of them
and say you want Andy you know what's
crazy Sean like thank god I'm in such a
better place to produce this show that I
was a month ago because I've been living
on the platform and reactants it's
making it better
I mean you seen it ya heard it it's been
work nine of it nothing like that I drag
the entire develop you live to 50 year
old marketing world in the snapchat yeah
and I told them and they know this I
didn't I didn't know what I was doing
but I just wanted to be on the record
I've been completely pumped so thankful
I didn't telling them the truth what I
didn't quantify was all the people that
follow me have now gotten bigger
themselves and their audiences so there
was more of a windfall than like things
that have happened in my past career
yeah some of these people now are big
yeah I'm really excited about what's
happening because for example Brandon
Marshall just texted me he's coming over
and the whole conversation right now is
gonna be me putting him on set it's
funny you said that because he is
literally one of the best like I assume
he'll be a broadcasting legend
first of all he's great like you so
literally literally 15 minutes yeah like
that's what's gonna happen I'm gonna be
putting out content every day alongside
of it to create context for this
audience
ya know just gonna make this show bad
like it's me great because we were
talking about like Obon seeing stuff
like the cleansing stuff happens
naturally because you're just already on
the platform talking it's why everything
loves with toner with the OEB and
snapchat
cuz I'm doing something snapchat then it
shows a man being like that's been the
biggest comment right now but daily be
like oh [ __ ] it's so cool because I saw
on snapchat happen live and then now I
see it actually what event there's a lot
of that I'm so purely true to this world
I'm like on the short list I know
there's a FAQ for sharks like I'm that
like seven people I'd rather I don't
want do that I won't do this yeah now if
you think it afford a team in an
environment we can and should also this
can transfer like you this could be
developed into a TV concept that you can
Brahma doodle i dude I don't come up but
this is bigger let's go to behavior much
bigger I don't want to be on TV I want
to be in fashion
alright so I I know what we need to do I
know we did it I'm not getting here so
because to pay and still understand
these deductions made better how are you
I mean everybody how you guys doing hey
guys from I gone Brandon pace are you
doing minute sit down sit down stuff and
bendin ha Sean's from snapchat oh really
and actually that's what I want to talk
to you about today well we got one we
got two seven pages up this here in the
off season now yeah
this where I have like 200 grams of
sugar today I'm ready yeah brah we're on
this looks like so just not wait what
weighing accelerator on yeah all right
what do you do not a Philadelphia sports
fan that's know who do you like no no
I'm a Johnson Oh a giant sir I think you
should watch together you're gonna judge
shines can I see green screen time I was
just saying I think you're gonna be like
in the broadcasting whole thing again
are starting eyes whatever gassing you
up I know you're big step walk I've
never read play that we all know that
but um I just left actually inside in a
fair we just tainted what happened your
Pacman Jones and he was really good it
was really good I need to see supposedly
but because we get things with it what
everyone likes is the interaction
between you player 2 player cuz it's
exactly 15 yeah but for me it was play
having a conversation or locker room of
course so I was like it's just a regular
car that hasn't been a nap there's not a
lot of active players doing it at that
serious of a level which adds a
different idea because everybody knows
it's a little different yeah I love
Chris Weber's commentary because it just
had that vibe doesn't seem like he's
bullshitting skills bro yeah keep up a
snowball
I appreciate that compliment alright
that down in other years this team King
we just had I would be like well we
wouldn't be in this team a weird like
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] open
if I can earn ma'am I had to fly that
[ __ ] LA after that Buffalo game
conducted in Chicago live in LA at 2:00
in the morning
la time which is 5 a.m. Senate mope my
[ __ ] ass put that to like I was
stunned how much that felt like a
playoff game yeah the Buffalo buffalo
game yeah so just like somebody who's
been to every Jets playoff game since 91
that felt like a playoff game really I
thought the big wing in the game was
crazy felt more like a playoff games in
a buffalo game I think for me it wasn't
closer like I had to really yeah I had
like bro like I was I was spit after
that game like I was I got everything I
had everything so throughout the week I
had two really fine yeah high-energy bro
like Matt Chad let's do this before you
do you have to do this who are will do
it another little wires here
no nothing snapchat about you being
scary right tell everybody why you're
scared of snapchat amen
snapchat boys too much action on snap it
what are you what are you building up
your Twitter Instagram mister very
poised more people watch your snapchat
than watch you on [ __ ] inside the NFL
yeah like it's just bigger and you think
man I know it is and you're [ __ ]
photogenic and charismatic and [ __ ]
creative and like you're just like you
need to like whatever it takes for me to
like get you around this you have to run
normally that was visually dude snap
[ __ ] please people are dying for me it's
just silly
you know why snapchats great it doesn't
have to be perfect it just needs to be
real yeah
I'm telling you man like you got cheat
like there's so many people winning that
don't have what you have it's just so
you know if you want to be entrepreneur
mixed up have like you'll have a hundred
people in your gym if you do snapchat
what do you think every [ __ ] 1822
year-olds look at no I'm telling you man
like please don't like be friends with
me it'd not be good at social media
that's just a student let you go to me
like like that is a real stupid mistake
I make no sense
no it oh man you know what's going on dj
khaled
yeah they don't want you to be here
again right and so you know we're gonna
do it over here with Gary it's gonna see
you
what strap we're fine you just not gonna
film yeah okay I gotta film a cm thing
real quick then I'll do that real quick
yeah no I need you first before you
Hannah can I meet with the important
people a sec they were in today the rain
today they're going to be back possibly
later this week okay you're not right
okay um you guys don't want to do that
you want me to connected just sucks okay
yep on snapchat yeah there's an
opportunity comes up the money is not me
that's okay this is political wonderful
cool cool thank you
you want to fly to Boston or you want to
take the train I like both Nasus woman
the plane is fastest I know I know you
like to take the train no I don't I
don't minutes anymore okay minutes are
gone man sir go
I think you should probably about 30
yeah I mean I will 100% clarify okay
then I'm cool with that
like I really do you guys big me
together it looks like a big me make me
four choices and it so can't be that go
ask Tyler actually open the door and ask
Tyler right now interrupt that meeting
and ask Tyler what it felt like to have
Gary drop the game-winner in your mouth
first thing you brought yeah it was a
really good one too I picked them up at
half-court like the five possessions
before that yeah than the one I don't
and I got a piece on it ended with
something a bit more money yeah he's
talking to her book stuff you got so you
have nothing else brueggen London right
now I'm having conversations but nothing
that I'm like we're not that far out
that's the other thing guys we're two
months out right literally walk your
pretty face with a great new beard often
and Ruby like Angela I eat up BSU for
London anything interesting potentially
at least two thousand out of our page
already never like things you think
we're gonna end up happening yeah yeah
Browns here okay Julie expand
universities yeah
hey Gary let's go oh yeah hello
I remember thinking about this and I
knew I had to fly out and like okay if
everyone's late and I like one thing to
say if we get together I'm gonna say the
Bolling if you do not separate the
people that are lucky to have mom and
dad do the right thing and they have no
debt from the people that literally have
hundreds of thousands of that that they
can't even use bankruptcy to get out of
if you not separate separate heavily the
way you communicate to those two groups
you have no shot it makes no sense
it's just it is you meet a first thing
but you guys all know this
the first impression in life and even
more so in marketing matters so much for
you to be as tone deaf to ask for money
from somebody has eighty-seven thousand
dollars of that and does not have a job
you pretty much locked yourself out of
consideration maybe forever and so if
you do not CRM those two groups out then
that would be a massive mistake to have
any sensibility in a 2016 data world
where you should be able to do that very
easily I would play up a lot more is you
know I would do like a I mean I'm going
really heavy with my Mia the immediate
company dreams but I would I mean this
is way out there so stick with me I
think there needs to be like little
videos that you put out about stories of
like the serendipity of who your college
roommate is and what they meant to your
life I think one of those mean maybe I'm
super affected by Adam Braun having Alex
Oro says his college roommate never
happened but I think the one
conversation in my land which is very
different for academia which is in pure
entrepreneur land is this is literally
verbatim of like the 15 16 year olds
that I talk to that have been already
accepted into MIT and Stanford and
literally are asking me crap student hey
should I go to college
I've been except I'm a 16 year old I've
been accepted to MIT but should I just
go to Silicon Valley instead and do my
thing and the one debate that is
happening at that level right now is
either I'll get a good network out of a
big-time school
like they are literally and I you know I
don't want to disrespect I'm just giving
you a lot of information of conversation
it is stunning
how much how little they're valuing the
education itself or the ability for that
organization's logo to help them at 20
to 24 it is literally down to who are
the other people and I think so he's
like pitch to a podcast for them to go
out and like to respond like every week
on an alum including housewife to CEO
the biggest company we can't go like to
show you 52 best success stories was
because I think that is an outrageously
important to our next conversation and
it is the value prop that the best of
the best right now that are going into
the organization are debating as the
number one KPI who are the seven people
I'm going to meet they're gonna help me
in the future which has always been
there but way more now way more now than
I think we've ever seen and then again
once you make these the reason I'm kind
of like landing on this and I like that
looks good black and white is because
we're going to show you a lot of black
and white besides a lot of Pam's upfront
stuff which is very tactically thought
about but once you decide what you want
to actually talk about that becomes the
real thesis of success here anything one
question of the ITO but videos or love
looks or production
you're talking to a guy who broke out on
YouTube in the first year of YouTube and
it looked like I was a hostage in
Afghanistan no lighting no audio and and
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is they overthink production here's what
I think it has never been easier to make
things look great for less money
yeah so first don't let money like if
it's going to cost you get at go with
like whatever happens um at the same
token I think the younger it is so
current a lot maybe just your first few
years out this man the rest of team
running around with iPhones more than
enough more than enough
I think overproduced speaks to the
insurance guy with a business like ah
the more I could get you to be in a snap
versus great lighting and perfect makeup
and a nice quality video that makes you
just not it just doesn't allow you
associate with that like holy crap you
were a snap with like that kind of like
there's a drawing in the bottom left
hand call it like that relevancy really
matters to that demo as you mate I mean
look if you're targeting your 60 and 70
and 80 year old um nine there's a debate
but again I'm so fearful of the aging
down aspects that are going on then I
don't want to go cliche that like okay
if they're over this age do this because
the speed in which the acceptance of
media consumption get a younger kind of
tactic is happening very quickly so if
it's costing you money I would punt that
if for some reason you can have the best
lighting of the best sound and there's
no overhead because you just happen to
have it there sure but not for every
situation so I really enjoyed the brown
meeting because you know whether it's
universities nonprofits people trying to
get voted for there's so many
applications of the modern-day
communication shifts we're living
through this whole social media aka
slang term for the modern web is a
something you can apply against anything
in the world that's the other thing
before I do that and so really liked
spreading my wings and talking to a
prestigious university about
opportunities in the future can you sign
this please
I too until our all this in there just
happen yep
I mean you're
just get going
here all the wires that you need and the
one that I got you today should charge
your phone like beats for the rest of my
life yeah Mike you don't ask what's
basketball
I think I think anybody wants to know if
they would exactly be an IV well super
we're going to Super Bowl okay
understand you and I are sharing hotel
they only had one hooked up for us I
think I'll promise on history beds and
one day a week echoes I said I prefer
two beds
we'll deal with one better we have to
move aside to me you go to these games
you I know but I want Motability
described is what Liguria might say this
Friday Clippers right yeah it's a good
one
make some progress in lieu of like I
want to be there as much as possible
right okay all right yep so I don't need
this call we do not need this go there
might be one or two other things to talk
about
there's a list go quick Oh
oh we need some